O
HANDOUTTY.
WE'LL OUT LINE A FAR LEFT PLAN
TO BOLLISH LAW AND ORDER AND
EMPOWER VIOLENT CRIMINALS JUST
WHEN YOU THOUGHT IT COULDN'T GET
WORSE.
THE ECONOMY IS IN A RECESSION AT
A 40 YEAR HIGH AND GAS PRICES
MORE THAN DOUBLED AND SUPPLY
CHAIN IS A DISASTER AND HOUSING
MARKET IN A HUGE TAIL SPIN AND
VIOLENT CRIME ON THE RISE IN
SMALL TOWNS AND BIG CITIES ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND
CALIFORNIA, THEY CAN'T KEEP THE
LIGHTS ON.
MEANWHILE BROAD EUROPE AT WAR
AND CHINA THREATEDDENNING TO
BLOW US UP AND REUNIFY WITH OUR
ALLY TAIWAN AND AFGHANISTAN IS
ONCE AGAIN A SAFE HAVEN FOR THE
TERRORISTS WHO PERPETRATED 9/11.
NOW NATURALLY ACCORDING TO JOE
BIDEN AND HIS FELLOW DEMOCRATS,
MAGA REPUBLICANS ARE THE
GREATEST THREAT TO AMERICA.
THAT'S THEIR PRIMARY CAMPAIGN
MESSAGE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE HAVE A ENOUGH REPUBLICANS
TO GET IT PAST BUT THE TRUTH IS
THERE'S A LOT MORE REPUBLICANS
TAKING CREDIT FOR THE BILL THAN
WE VOTED FOR.
WE'RE BUILDING THIS NEW BRIDGE
HERE AND WE'RE ALL FOR IT.
WE'LL HAVE AN INTERNET.
I LOVE HIM, MAN.
THEY AIN'T GOT NO SHAME.
NO SHAME.
REPUBLICANS HAVE AWAKENED A
POWERFUL THING IN THIS NATION.
WOMEN.
NO, I'M NOT JOKING.
I'M NOT JOKING.
>> Sean: THEY'VE GOT NO SHAME.
THIS COMING FROM THE GUY THAT
USED HIS OWN CRACK ADDICTED SON
AS A BAGMAN BASICALLY.
A GUY WHO CHEATED HIS WAY
THROUGH LAW SCHOOL AND IMAGINE
PLAGIARIZED HIS WAY THROUGH THE
SENATE AND LIED ABOUT BEING A
CIVIL RIGHTS ACTIVIST AND WORKED
WITH SEGREGATIONIST AND STOP
INTEGRATION OF THE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND DIDN'T WANT THEM TO
BECOME RACIAL JUNGLES, HIS
WORDS.
HE CHECKED HIS WATCH SEVERAL
TIMES DURING THE CEREMONY FOR
THE 13 FALLEN U.S. SERVICE
MEMBERS THAT WERE KILLED BECAUSE
OF HIS BOTCHED WITHDRAWAL IN
AFGHANISTAN.
JOE BIDEN HAS NO SHAME.
JOE BIDEN HAS NO CLASS, NO
HONOR, NO DIGNITY, NO MORALS.
I DON'T THINK HE HAS ANY CLUE
WHAT DAY IT IS, AND NOW HE HAS A
BARELY FUNCTIONING BRAIN.
HILLARY CLINTON MEANWHILE IS
JUST DESPERATE FOR ATTENTION.
DOSES ANYBODY REALLY CARE WHAT
SHE HAS TO SAY?
YESTERDAY SHE DECLARED THAT
CERTAIN REPUBLICANS HAVE GOT TO
BE PURGED MUCH LIKE A DISEASE.
SHE ACTUALLY SAID IT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> FOR REASONS THAT ARE REALLY
HARD TO FULLY UNDERSTAND, THERE
IS MAJOR POLITICAL PARTIES WHO
SUPPORT IT AND THEY SUPPORT AND
SEEMINGLY AT ODDS WITH DEMOCRACY
AT THE BEST THING THAT COULD
HAPPEN FOR THE COUNTRY AND
FRANKLY FOR WHAT'S LEFT OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
IT'S TO DEFEAT AS MANY
CANDIDATES THEY HAVE RUNNING NOW
AT ALL LEVELS, NATIONAL, STATE,
AND LOCAL AND FORS THEM TO PURGE
THEIR PARTY OF THE DISEASE THAT
HAS SPREAD.
>> Sean: PURGE DEPLORABLE AND
REDEEMABLE AND RELIGION AND
SMELLY TRUMP WAL-MART SHOPPERS
OR IN THIS CASE MAGA REPUBLICANS
AND HILLARY ECHOING JOE BIDEN
WANTS TO PURGE MAGA REPUBLICANS
AND LET'S BE CLEAR, ALMOST NO
ONE ON EARTH ACTUALLY LIKES OR
RESPECTS HILLARY CLINTON AND
SHE'S NEVER GOON BE PRESIDENT.
BUT HER REMARKS PERFECTLY
ENCAPSULATE WHAT IS THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY'S MIDTERM
MESSAGE.
THEY WANT YOU TO TURN A BEHIND
EYE TO ALL THE VIOLENT CRIME,
THE FAILING SCHOOLS, ALL THE
ECONOMIC SUFFERING OF THEIR
INSANE COVID POLICIES, THEIR
CLIMATE CULTISM, AND JUST FOCUS
ON HATING MAGA REPUBLICANS AND
IN OTHER WORDS FOCUS ON HATING
HALF THE COUNTRY AND THEY'RE IN
THE PROCESS OF RENAMING NOW
FEDERAL LANDS WITH WORDS THAT
DON'T OFFEND THEM.
650 RENAMINGS APPARENTLY.
NOW, DON'T LET THEM GASLIGHT
YOU.
WE NEED THIS COUNTRY BACK ON
TRACK.
THAT IS WH